or staying in the US making their own
demands for Trump's removal from power
on Saturday where thousands of
protesters in Washington and across the
u.s. now they held rallies marking the
third anniversary of the women's March
that drew millions of protesters to the
streets today after Trump's inauguration
in 2017 as well as the main event in
Washington rallies were held in Chicago
New York and Los Angeles
protesters say Trump must go in order to
protect diversity equality and human
rights Gabriela's Ando was at one of the
rallies in Washington DC despite the
cold temperatures and nearly freezing
rain it hasn't stopped thousands of
people from coming out on the streets
here in Washington DC for the fourth
annual Women's March the first one
happened in January 2017 and it was in
response to President Donald Trump's
inauguration in that March it was almost
like a protester will more than a
million people throughout the United
States that took part in that in 2017
this one is much different there's only
a few thousand people here nevertheless
everyone here says that while the
numbers are much much smaller that it's
important that they're here for us it's
so much bigger than that for us it's
about the impact that people are able to
have when they go back into their
communities for us it's about people
coming here getting inspired getting
motivated and taking that energy back
into their communities to focus on local
organizing I think the marginalized
populations african-americans LGBTQ and
Hispanics which I'm part of that culture
if we don't all get together and stand
up nothing's gonna change and all of us
collectively can make that change happen
most people here tell us that it doesn't
matter if Trump is re-elected or not
they're gonna carry on this movement for
years to come there's already talk about
may be another's women's March later
this year closer to the election